hello everybody happy Tuesday morning
time for round two of the gratitude
journal livestream if you guys didn't
catch it yesterday one of the things I
do with my team every day is we've got a
Facebook group and we share three things
that were grateful for at the beginning
of our day just to kind of start our day
off on the right foot and again if you
look at any happiness research you'll
see that gratitude is a key component of
it and it's hard to be grateful for
something as well as being angry and
upset at the same time and so getting
into the daily habit of sharing into
your food before is super helpful it's
been quicker for myself and my team and
so I thought why not bring it to belief
nation as well so that you guys have
something in the morning to uh to be
grateful for think about you're dead and
the key thing here for me too is that
it's it's daily this is what I do daily
I'm gonna start to share with you guys
live but it's not just a one-time thing
right like we have a nice shot at energy
yesterday but it's being consistent with
because you may feel grateful in that
moment but then you wake up the next day
and it's all calm and so it's
consistently being grateful showing
gratitude thinking of why you're lucky
and it just at least for me makes a big
difference on the impact on my life so
what I'd like to do is share three more
things today that I'm grateful for and
hopefully you guys in the chat watching
live will share three things that you're
grateful for today as well as those are
you watching the replay out there what
are you grateful for and hopefully
coming back every day consistently so
you're joining in the process just like
I am and my team deal so again we were
thinking about what are you grateful for
it's it's really trying to feel it not
just listing off some things but try to
put yourself in that moment and spending
kind of five to ten seconds actually
feeling the gratitude and so I'm
thinking about today you're not really
gave me for my parents there up on the
wall behind me and believe kings from
them and they didn't make me feel like I
had to be
anybody but myself they would always
tell me that I was a fist really karma
come and do anything I wanted and that's
a tradition I continued today with my
son
eight and seven years old you know I'm
picking up from school today and one of
the things that you every time I see him
is I say I'm getting carmichael and I
can do and he always says anything and
so I really learned that from my parents
and I try to pass that on to my son and
so I know not not everybody has the good
fortune of having such amazing parents
like I did so we're looking for that too
I'm people for you guys you know believe
nation the YouTube audience I think
about what I do day in and day out and
one of the best parts of my day is
getting up and look at the comments and
seeing the impact and watching the
videos and seeing how much it's touched
to you guys even though this like
supporting my experiments in joining
along for the ride and you know those
are you watching live and sharing your
experiences and you know it's I never
would have imagined this five years ago
but this is where I would be testing out
this YouTube thing and having an
audience and so if you don't build the
whole business around it now and it's
one of the best parts of what I do and
regular basis and so you know I'm super
grateful for you guys enjoying in what
I'm doing every day and number three for
me I'm Alex Alex runs from Dan salsa and
this morning he he brought me a coffee
and he he was rushing if I didn't want
to be late
you know I say good things about him in
public
yeah here here at the one minute early
and and had to get into Starbucks I get
hit the drinks and a $2.00 more than
going to his favorite second cup and
came inside and almost called me maybe
so that was
romance the permit some good over Alex
I'm cool
that's what I met before I'm feeling
good this morning
my throat's did a lot of video recording
yesterday for some new videos are coming
up so I can I talk myself dry but the
coffee and some tea and a bunch of other
things are here I don't know you for
today Tuesday morning what are you doing
what do you think before let's start off
on the right foot
I'm gonna read them out so uh let's see
we got we she kept TBD feeling grateful
a new day I love it and think about that
too for you guys it's like the gratitude
can be something big like thinking my
parents or something super small right
like the kindness so I'm going to copy
your vehicle for a sunshine of engineer
you know there's always have to be some
big thing you gave before could be just
a small thing that you know is just
super thankful for today what else
hey rise preach gratitude rishi cup cup
of love Buffy your voice is rocky
YouTube live voice sucks I think that is
what my voice than YouTube live today as
I mentioned I was record in life not
live according a bunch of videos
yesterday the book video series where I
mean excerpts from a book my book and a
couple other books and when I'd get into
reading I get super passionate excited
about it and so I chose my voice I might
hit a little bit scary because I have to
go and read on three days in October the
whole day from my book make the audio
version of my book from 10:00 to 5:00
and I'm so pumped but I also don't want
to lose my voice I'm sure he rice has
some magic solutions for me but when I'm
when I'm reading man I pour my heart
into it new future builder I am grateful
for my wife and her patients I love that
I mean I think I meant she said
yesterday on the stream I love it what
else but be expressive releasing in the
afternoon I won in the morning it just
suggests just suggest you can watch in
the morning
g-guys grateful for all the solid
furniture solid furniture to work eat
create play and use I like it
people for furniture I love it wrinkles
are strong miraculous robust body's
immune systems and metabolisms yeah I
agree there too and I also like I'm
victim I'd my throat's a little hoarse
today because it it makes me realize
that when I have my voice solid how how
much I love it right sometimes you need
to down to appreciate the ups grateful
for powerful inspiring stories left the
Haven tale Evan G's Jerry I love it oh
it's coming in that's coming in what
else you got
before believe in a change showing up
for this yeah I mean to guy I mean
that's what I mentioned at the top I'm
grateful you guys support me I'm doing
all the experiments and this is an app
that you guys leave more year people for
here I'm people for oxygen since there's
little warming problems increasing I
love it people for the air that you
breathe
today no I'm ripped off at the time I
got to spend with my best friend even
though that's no longer possible that's
uh that's that's rough man I don't know
what happened there but I'm sorry that
I'm with him anymore but but it is good
that you can hold on to those memories
that you didn't spend together
Dallas they're still worth people for
health health is wealth I love it
Antoine clerk Renault coming in from
Quebec Canada people for being alive
actually in doing what I love what else
the sound quality is definitely messed
up a bit
oh is it it's not just me okay good you
might need to fix your stuff Jen much
I'm greeting from my hands my hands to
write with touch with play with hold
with and cook
drive eat they express so much more hash
tag hands I love it I love it oh that's
going crazy what else we got
singing just love in the water and kind
of yes thank you I will
I gotta use that I remember to do that
when I've got when I do my own videos
too but I didn't make myself some nettle
tea
courtesy of joy rises but as I think it
just feels better in her Starbucks cup I
had initial starts cup so I just put my
own tea in there honey so I got it for
today because I'm heading off to the
live League of Legends stream with Ricci
in one minute what else we got what else
we got lots of comments about the voice
lagging stream being I apologize for
that guys I don't know what's going on
hey try being almost with no furniture I
feel a minute I feel that your eyes
Mariah I'm grateful for being able to
learn and improve every day I love it
bubby it's Tuesday evening hey you know
what never too late to show some
gratitude morning evening any time of
day show that gratitude I love the more
comments coming in thank you guys it's
9:10 that's it that's the end of the
stream I'll see you tomorrow morning for
those you want to join in and now I'm
heading off to my twitch channel to do a
live business Q&A League of Legends
challenge with Rishi TV have a great day
guys continue to believe whatever your
one word is